alright let's keep taking calls out
let's go next to the caller from the 918
area code caller what's your name in
recalling from uh yeah my name is keith
and i'm calling from orlando florida all
right two calls in a row from Orlando
Keith what's going on yes so arm I'm not
sure if you saw it or not but yesterday
the CEO of Twitter Jack Dorsey
interviewed Edward Snowden I didn't see
that and I was just what so I was just
wondering what you think um you know the
Trump administration seems pretty
hostile towards the idea of a pardon or
you know a lesser sentence yeah I was
just wondering what you felt about that
in terms of how likely i think it is
that we would see Edward Snowden
pardoned or in terms of what I think
should happen uh both if you can okay I
see it as incredibly unlikely that
Edward Snowden would be pardoned by the
incoming from administration uh
partially because of that there's an
intertwined relationship there with all
of the Russia stuff that's going on and
I think that if Trump is is smart and he
claims to be which is why he says he
doesn't need daily intelligence
briefings the only need them weekly cuz
he's so smart if he's smart I don't
think he would try to entangle himself
too much in a really visible way with
Russia so that you know CEO Rex
Tillerson can go and make deals in
whatever else he's planning to do so my
sense is that it would be insanely
public if Donald Trump were to do
something like that the counter to that
would be maybe Donald Trump would sort
of see himself as being able to tout how
in favor of disclosure and transparency
and free speech he is by doing something
it doesn't seem President Obama is going
to do insofar as pardoning Edward
Snowden or more than likely would be
agreeing to some kind of lesser sentence
and of course it would be completely
counter to the total lack of
transparency that we see from Trump in
reality with regard to taxes with regard
to business holdings etcetera but from
an optics perspective there's a play
there that Donald Trump could make but
if I had to bet I'm not a betting man
but if I had to bet I'd say we don't see
a pardon of Snowden uh number two
no I think that the the important thing
with Snowden is we have to distinguish
between uh whistleblowers and leakers
and what Edward Snowden exposed while
completely deplorable and we now know
not useful in terms of the surveillance
he exposed it had been made legal by
statute including the Patriot Act and
other surveillance laws that were passed
so from a legal perspective Edward
Snowden is not a whistleblower that I
know to a lot of people doesn't really
matter because he exposed incredibly
wasteful and and add a self-destructive
behavior by spy surveillance and
intelligence agencies and I agree with
that so I think that it would not be a
bad thing if Edward Snowden were brought
back to the United States and I also the
intelligence value bringing Edward
Snowden back to the US to learn more
about how he did what he did etcetera
would have significant value I don't
know that a pardon sets the right
precedent I don't know what do you think
well I I would have to agree I agree
he's not technically a whistleblower
yeah but you know that the contribution
to the public discourse that he's
provided you know maybe a a probation
sentence or something like that would be
appropriate not throwing them in jail
yeah I think that that is a lot to ask
for you know I think if a deal is going
to be made it would be for maybe less
jail time that he'd been would he would
otherwise face but will ultimately see
thank you so much for the call I really
really appreciate it always great to
hear from our viewers and listeners in
Florida